don't rip people off
if you want to have long-term success if
you want to get repeat customers if you
want to get referred business you can't
rip your clients off
i just came back from a cruise vacation
with carnival and went to europe for
almost two weeks
and while the actual cruise ship was a
great deal it was great value
if you think about how much i would
spend to go to nine cities in 10 days
and spend travel costs and hotel costs
and food costs the cruise ship was
actually a great value for me but
everything else on board was a massive
rip-off
you on internet you're paying almost a
dollar a minute you want to go on a tour
with them you're paying 10 times what it
would cost you to do it on your own
everything is way more expensive
i remember the first time i went up and
saw the internet rates this little sheet
posted outside
and if you do pay as you go it's almost
a dollar per minute if you buy hundreds
of minutes on the first day then you get
a discounted price
all the way down to 50 cents per minute
are you kidding me
how much of a rip-off is this
and everybody who sees that sign who
tries to sign up and get online feels
the exact same thing
like they're getting ripped off
and you do not want your customers
walking away from your business feeling
like they're getting ripped off because
are they going to come back are they
gonna tell their friends are gonna rave
about how great you are
i don't think so
i voted with my wallet
instead of buying their internet package
whenever i docked i found the starbucks
and think about that
carnival now has this negative
reaction for me because i feel like they
ripped me off or they tried to
meanwhile starbucks
has a positive reaction
because i know i can go there and get my
wi-fi
i sought them out wherever i went i
looked for our starbucks
that's the power of the branding
and what did i do when i got to the
starbucks i also bought a coffee
i spent my dollars with the companies
that were giving me real value
so the next time you're thinking about
how you're going to charge for your
products and services
do a couple things
first make sure there's incredible value
you only want to charge when there's
something that's absolutely over the top
incredibly valuable for the customer you
want them to walk away feeling grateful
that they met you
feeling grateful that they spent dollars
with you
because then they're gonna love it and
then they're gonna tell their friends
about it then they're going to come back
more and more and more
so put way more value
into what you're selling
and two when you're looking at upselling
and cross-selling
i'm a huge believer in upselling
it's a great way to grow business sell
more to current customers is a fantastic
way to grow your business
but again make sure
it's only
huge value that they're getting
the hardest part is getting that initial
sale you're building up trust
accountability
belief in what you're all about
it's a lot easier to upsell them once
you've proven yourself
but every upsell has to be great
experience you want them walking away
from every single purchase with you
feeling great
last time i checked you didn't have tons
of you know millions of dollars to go
and spend on tv campaigns you're not
buying super bowl commercials you need
word of mouth marketing and repeat
business and that comes from not ripping
off your clients
and i know there's a temptation to think
hey i've got them in the store or
they've come to me for the first time
they're buying i may never see these
guys again
i should milk them for as much as i can
this is quick money right now i need
cash they are money right now
it's such a short term view of the world
and of your business
the lifetime value of that customer is
so much higher
than just one purchase
and if you treat every single customer
as a potential lifelong client and one
that will keep coming back and refer
clients to you you'll have so much more
success long term and you'll feel better
about yourself and what you're doing
do you like ripping off your clients
you'll feel so much better have a lot
more fun with your company when you see
that people love
what it is that you're offering and feel
like they're getting great value
so do it today look at everything you're
selling look at every upsell cross-sell
every product and service you're putting
out there
and really examine it honestly
truthfully
is what you're providing extremely
valuable to your customers do they walk
away
loving the experience and the service
and the value that they're getting from
you and if not then i challenge you
to make your business better make your
offering better and wow your customers
with every experience they have with
your company
that's the path to long-term success as
a business owner
and a lot more happiness too
believe
for those of you watching you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
it makes want to do more for you and i'd
love to hear what you have to think
hopefully you're not ripping off your
clients let me know in the comments
below if you have a question put the
comments below too i'll answer it do a
video response thank you guys i'll see
you soon